you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's program
the billion pound gigafactory leading
the way in the uk's electric
car revolution he's back
arnold schwarzenegger hosts the austrian
world summit pledging to terminate
air pollution and how insects could be
the solution to reducing deforestation
in the amazon
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
and we've got lots coming up today
including how
sea otters are helping to keep
california's marine ecosystem
healthy but first a one billion pound
electric vehicle hub
including a new battery gigafactory has
been announced by nissan
based in sunderland the car maker says
it will bring together electric vehicles
renewable energy and battery production
in a world
first ev manufacturing ecosystem
now the site which would be the uk's
largest gigafactory is expected to open
in 2024
and will produce 9 gigawatt hours of
battery capacity a year
that's enough to power 100 000 vehicles
now to put that into context the
existing sunderland plant
only produces 1.9 gigawatt hours of
batteries
at the moment but with the sale of new
petrol and diesel cars
banned from 2030 far more investment in
batteries and electric vehicles will be
needed
the society of motor manufacturers and
traders says at least
60 gigawatt hours of giga factory
capacity will be needed in the uk
by the end of the decade well our
business correspondent paul kelso has
more from nissan's sunderland plant
the shift to electrification here at
nissan has been driven by
two factors the government has said by
2030
new internal combustion engine vehicle
production is going to be
banned so they will have to be electric
and there's a brexit
factor too the deal done between the eu
and the uk government
means that before 2030 the bulk
of the electric vehicles value its
battery is going to have to be produced
in the uk or in europe or they will
attract tariffs
when they're exported so there are sound
financial reasons for this ship
the project to build a huge gigafactory
here is an attempt not just to green the
cars
but to green the entire process it's
intended to be 100
renewable energy fueled by huge
solar plant that's being built here
funded with 80 million
pounds of taxpayer money from sunderland
city council the government's also
putting in
tens of millions more so the shift to
electrification
while necessary won't be happening
without taxpayers
helping pay for it arnold schwarzenegger
has told sky news
countries need to show leadership on
climate change and stop waiting for
others to take action
he's hosting the austrian world summit
in vienna which brings together heads of
state and government
as well as business leaders and
activists to discuss efforts to reduce
global emissions well adam parsons is
there and adam and he's got a tough
message for world leaders then
yeah and they've been listening to him
this is a spanish riding school
in vienna one of the city's best known
buildings converted
for the summit today and the cast list
who's been here has included
presidents and prime ministers and
politicians alex sharma
was here on behalf of the government
nicholas sturgeon
among those coming but really the
standout performers that this audience
have been listening to will have been
two
of those uh one of them was arnold
schwarzenegger come to him in a moment
the other one was greta tumber
who launched the latest of her absolute
double barrel shotgun caustic criticisms
of governments politicians and what she
described as a
high income nation she said i've been
using
empty words rhetoric hadn't done
anything the list
went on i have to say alex sharma
nicholas sturgeon had to listen to that
and put on rather awkward smiles the
other person you'll be
expecting will be arnold schwarzenegger
and we caught up with him
to talk about climate change and of
course the forthcoming
cop 26 in the uk here's what he had to
say you shouldn't just
always think that the cop events
are the only solution it's a very good
solution but not the only one
we should also build a from the ground
up movement we should educate the public
so that they are with the programs that
they know what the dangers are
and the dangers that lie ahead and it
has nothing to do with politics it has
to do with one thing
let's go and get rid of pollution
because pollution
kills people the chinese and the indians
are
putting out enormous amount of issues
emissions they're not
here is there any point in the sense of
of really a climate change policies that
don't include
those two giant industrial nations well
i think that uh
we shouldn't limit ourselves and to
think that the only way we get things
done is
if everyone is in on it i don't remember
john f kennedy saying we are not going
to send the man to the moon
unless the chinese also send a man to
the moon unless the russians send the
main to the moon unless the european
center i mean
no he said we're going to be the first
ones and we're going to go and do it
so that's leadership so i think at this
meeting what you've really had is the
carrot
of mr schwarzenegger saying we've got to
be ambitious and the stick of greta
timber
saying young people around the world
expect action and they
are not seeing it one final thought
though from schwarzenegger he said lots
of people just don't understand all the
terminology they don't understand what
net zero is they don't understand what
carbon credits are
what you need is a single clear message
for him that message was this
get rid of pollution adam thank you
in today's other climate news the world
meteorological organization has
recognised a new
record high temperature for the
antarctic the 18.3 degrees celsius
reading was taken on the 6th of february
last year
at a research base on the continent's
northwest tip
one of the fastest warming regions on
earth the committee rejected an even
higher temperature of 20.75 degrees
which was reported three days later on
seymour island
rishi sunak has promised to tackle
climate targets by
forcing businesses to report their
environmental impact
speaking at manchin house the chancellor
said the new
integrated sustainability disclosures
requirements
will come into effect before the cop 26
conference in november
he also announced details of a new green
bond which the treasury hopes will raise
at least
15 billion pounds the queen has said
we're going to have to change the way we
do things during a visit to the
university of edinburgh's climate change
institute
the monarch arrived in style in an
electric hybrid land rover
and spoke to students and staff about
their research into ways to reverse the
effects of global warming
at the end of the visit her majesty was
presented with two trees that will be
planted as part of a special initiative
to celebrate her platinum jubilee next
year
and scientists say sea otters are
playing a big part in the fight against
climate change
the furry creatures are helping keep
california's marine forests healthy
by eating sea urchins whose numbers have
risen dramatically in the area
urchins had been over grazing on kelp
forests which play
a vital role in absorbing carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere
bangladesh is one of the world's most
densely populated countries with people
living along a delta of rivers that
empty into the bay of bengal
two-thirds of the country is less than
five metres above sea level
and climate change is threatening the
lives and livelihoods of those on the
country's coast
sea surface temperatures in the tropical
indian ocean rose by
one degree between 1951 and 2015.
the rate of warming is the fastest
amongst tropical oceans
and accounts for a quarter of the
increase in global oceanic heat
over the last two decades as the oceans
get warmer
sea levels rise due to a process called
thermal expansion that's when water
expands
as it gets hotter the rise in sea
temperatures and global warming are also
linked to the intensity of tropical
cyclones
between 2000 and 2018 there was a
significant rise in the frequency
of very severe cyclonic storms in the
area
and higher sea levels and receding
coastlines mean storm surges cause
even more damage skies caterina vitozi
has been visiting the villages
already suffering these effects of our
changing climate
including calabogie where houses have
been raised off the ground on bamboo
sticks
and the land divided by the rising river
on bangladesh's south coast homes don't
just flood
they disappear
we're heading to a village called
calabogie
surrounded by a rising river
battered by cyclones this land of mud
and sediment is being washed away
taking homes and hope along
[Music]
can
rising sea levels in the bay of bengal
downstream
mean river tides here are getting higher
storm surges are more intense and
dangerous
over there about 500 meters away is a
small island with homes on it
until about a year ago that was
connected
to this bit of land and it wasn't just a
road to walk on it was a stretch of land
that had homes on it where people lived
and when you see this and you think
about climate change goals and climate
change targets you like to think that
action can make a difference but really
for people living here it's already too
late
this is why bangladesh says the world
must act
with this year's climate conference
needed not to talk about what will
happen but about what's happening right
here
right now catherine of autopsy sky news
in kalibogi bangladesh
and a reminder that you can hear more
from katarina in bangladesh in this
week's episode of climate cast
it's out tomorrow and you can find it
wherever you normally get your podcast
from
now there might be a bit of a buzz
around this next story as researchers
have found that
insects could help stop deforestation in
the amazon
a study commissioned by wwf and tesco
found that using insect meal to feed
fish and livestock
could cut the uk's use of soy by a fifth
and help protect important habitats
in the process here's how
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's everything from us for today
coming up tomorrow the difficult choice
facing uganda as it struggles to
reconcile a huge oil project and the
economic benefits it would bring
with world-leading laws to protect
nature thanks for watching
see you then